《红楼梦》第四十三回,闲取乐偶船金庆寿,家母提出船前给阿凤过生日。在船前过程中,王熙凤当着家母的面建议,让人去问一下两位以奶奶,看他俩要不要出钱。
最终周照两位以娘只得每人出二两阴子,原住是这么写的。
奉劫又笑到,上下都全了,还有二位以奶奶,他出不出也问一声,进到他们势力,不然他们只当小看了他们了。
家母听了,忙说,可是呢,怎么到忘了他们,只怕他们不得闲,叫一个压头问问去,说着早有压头去了。
半日回来说到,每位也出二两,王熙凤提这个建议完全是使坏,周照二位以娘都离没几个钱,
奉劫利用家母的危言,命人去问两位以娘,他们就算都离干净,也得挤出几个钱来应充面子。
原住写的很有生意,问话的压换半日才回来,这个半日就表明周照两位以娘紧张且矛盾。
家母亲自派人来问,他们只能出钱,但具体出多少钱只能细细悬纹压换,得知家母行王夫任,离完优势众姐妹所出的营养后,这才挑选了最末一等的二两赢子。
事情并没有结束,当身在一旁的优势看穿了王熙凤的心思后,他暗暗骂了凤结两句,而凤结的回话责引人深思。
由是因敲骂凤结道,我把你这没诅厌的小提子,这么些婆婆审则来臭赢子给你过生日,你还不足,又拉上两个苦护子做什么。
凤结也敲笑道,你少胡说,一回子离了这里,我才和你算账,他们两个为什么苦呢?
有了钱也是白田送别人,不如居来咱们乐。
凤结说,周兆两位一娘,有了钱也是白田送别人,这个别人是谁,红楼梦里似乎没有名言。
我们先来计算一下,红楼梦里一娘的乐钱奋利。
原住第36回,王夫任内定习人为准一娘时,就曾提到过一娘的乐钱为每月二两赢子一掉钱。
照是登上一娘之位,最保守估计也有十年至十五年。
毕竟亲生女儿探春都已经是十几岁的少女了,我们就去最保守的十年。
这十年里,赵一娘的乐力累积是240两,外加120掉钱。
过去有读者会觉得,钱这个东西也拿有指尽不出的道理。
赵一娘十年间未必能累积下这么多钱,他难道不用花钱吗?
荣国府是一个特殊的存在,只要进了这座国工府,基本就算端上了铁饭碗。
人人都有各自的生活奋力,基本不用额外花钱。
也正因这个道理,第四十五回,王西奉就曾一次调砍礼完。
说他主政奴才吃的穿的都是观中的。
一年能累积下四五百两赢子,却不愿意拿点钱办试顺。
当然,周赵两位一娘的身份和礼完固然不是一个级别,但生活模式差别不大。
一娘也有固定的吃穿奋力,只是级别叫低。
只要赵一娘花钱不大手大脚,每年二十四两赢子是一定能载下来的。
说的再细一些,赵一娘的实际奋力恐怕还要多一些。
因为她儿子讲完的越历,也由赵一娘领取,也是每月二两。
女儿探春则因为思想独立,早早从赵一娘那里将经济大权拿走。
故而第二十七回,探春击赞下十几掉钱,交给甲宝玉外出採购。
可见探春完全花自己的钱,赵一娘耐和她不得。
如此一来,赵一娘的越历加上儿子甲环的越历,每年至少四十八两赢子。
另外,甲环上学之后,每年还有吃点心,买纸笔的八两赢子。
虽然后来探春,心里除速笔,把这八两赢子给捐了,
可这笔钱到底曾长时间存在过,我们不能忽略她。
如此一算,赵一娘似乎不应该是优势口中的苦户子。
她虽不是大夫大贵,但口袋里怎么说也有个小康之家的赢子数。
可从书中来关,赵一娘似乎确实很穷。
第二十五回,马道婆来访赵一娘,想要两块布当鞋面子。
可抗伤的仇断,全都是些碎布。
赵一娘就这些碎布沾鞋,看着有些寒酸。
第四十三回,奉劫生日所凑赢两不过二两赢子,都能让赵一娘思存半日。
后来有事将二两赢子还了回来,周赵两位一娘又是惊喜又是害怕,
担心被奉劫抓住把柄,最终在优势的撑腰下才敢把赢子拿回来。
也就是说,王西风的话说的没错,周赵两位一娘暗里并不穷,
但由于某些原因,他们把钱全都填送了别处,
导致日常生活中要花钱,反而捉尽剑走进路平台。
原住对周一娘的描述很少,我们难以分析,但赵一娘的大手大脚却是有记录的。
仍是第25回,马道婆拜访赵一娘时就诚问。
前日我送了五百钱去,在药王跟钱上供,你可收了没有。
马道婆道早已替你上了供了。
赵一娘探口气道,恶蜜脱佛,
我手里淡凡从容歇,也时常的上个共,只是心有余力量不足。
人文社板红楼梦对药王的解释是这样的。
药王,菩萨民,佛教经典中有药王药上二菩萨,
传入中国后受到供奋,但远不如民间信仰影响大。
民间传说以神农或扁确为药王,
亦说唐代孙思苗为药王,认为起求药王可以预病。
无论那种解释,药王都有求健康保平安的意义,
赵一娘所供奋的药王,跟后文是对应的。
他起求平安健康,却又买通马道婆给王西奉甲保育下骨,
导致两人梦眼握床,几乎病死,充满农农的粉丝意味。
赵一娘日子过的轻皮却能拿出五百钱上共,
并且延称,我手里淡凡从容鞋,也时常的上个共。
可见在国公府深宅大院之中,
像赵一娘这样的中年妇女,只能把精神寄脱在虚幻的信仰上。
即使莫说赵一娘,家母王父任何层不是一样。
故而家序本师头记第25回,回莫批语就解释到,
此回本意是未尽三孤六婆,进门之害,难以防范。
表明,重然是国公府,家母王父任赵一娘这些中老年妇女,
王母王容易受骗。
金平美里也有相同的情况。
西门庆就非常严股削孤子,认为他是打着信仰的谎子骗钱,
可西门庆的正期无愿娘,却对削孤子十分信任。
家中有人生病,就找削孤子来治病,可见三孤六婆之害自古接人。
赵一娘一次就拿出五百钱上供,在那漫长的十多年里,
她又拿出多少钱上供,我们不得而知。
原本还算小康的口袋,硬是被上供,上成了平寒之家。
从一些细节来看,赵一娘对马道婆的信任也是十分兼顾的。
为了让马道婆给保奉输扫两人下股,赵一娘赶想赶赶,
拿出自己全部的积蓄和手势,又写了一张五百两营资的欠气。
这一下,就把自己未来二十多年的月前全部提前之出了。
后来赖头盒上,薄足到人亲自出场,就加了王夕奉和甲宝玉。
赵一娘的积蓄和那五百两营资算是打了水漂。
事情没办成,她是否需要给马道婆还钱,这一点前八十回没有提及。
可能曹雪晴也觉得,三孤六婆的文字点到为止,多写就俗了。
倒是高恶所需后四十回,写到了马道婆被官府秦拿,供出了赵一娘当年下股的事。
但布红军个人以为,续输写的并不好。
情节逻辑漏洞十分明显,独之难以深思,就不单独拎出来余意解读分析了。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。